today I'm the show man wonder women and
mirror go swimming actual healing and
preacher premiere is a lot more on
today's Batman I'm Batman tada
[Music]
welcome to fat man I'm Batman I'm Kevin
Smith mark barnard we sorry we missed
you a few days last week we were working
on stuff but we're back and we got so
many things to cover three new episodes
this week starting today with two other
episodes to follow in the days that
follow I got lost but you know what
before we go any further yeah this is
fun I talked about in Hollywood
babble-on couple weeks ago but got it do
it here because it was born here we're
talking about Deadpool yes or talking
about Deadpool fellating Deadpool it's
gonna be the greatest movie ever and a
lot of news sites picked that up and
said like on Fatman I'm Batman Kevin
Smith over spoke the obvious and so
remember I was sitting there going like
this [ __ ] Tim Miller kid the director
is Tim Miller this Tim Miller kid he's
got the [ __ ] world by the balls he'd
do anything after this man Deadpool
cracked the code and he's gonna [ __ ]
doing this kid he get his old futures
ahead of him I got an email from Tim
Miller in that [ __ ] funny cuz we
talked about on the show somebody sent
him the clip to watch and he sent me an
email and I asked him can I read it and
he said yes so I'm gonna read it to
storytime with ya Batman I'm Batman fan
mailbag digging into the utility belt
pulling out fan mail from famous [ __ ]
man I'm saying he's directed Deadpool
and [ __ ] taking me places mm-hmm mark
you were joking
hey Kevin what up I'm gonna be in
deadpool tim miller here I'm the
director of Deadpool saw the show thanks
a ton for all the compliments and
goodwill two things though sounds like a
but we just got friends and all sudden
[ __ ] now he's up in my grill number
one you actually sort of know me I
directed a Batman commercial last year
that you really liked young Bruce Wayne
growing into Batman remember that
commercial yeah [ __ ] video game this
commercial have you haven't seen it
probably the best Batman movie ever made
it's nuts it shows young Bruce Wayne as
a boy and he's standing between his
parents and you don't see his parents
just headshot the whole time and he's
like bright and happy like a kid is and
they'll sudden there's a flash like the
gunshot going off and yes and the bodies
next to them kind of move and you watch
his expression like drop into horror and
then they do like these smash cuts jump
cuts like Bam Bam Bam into Bruce Wayne
growing up right and the voice-over is
all like the reading of like oh not this
one this one is a [ __ ] song well I
thought it was the one we it's the
Thomas Wings last last letter to bat is
a different one with the car in it right
this is the one where it's just the boy
and I forget what the [ __ ] song I was
but it was just it was so beautiful dude
there's no dialogue it's just [ __ ]
the horror of this kid's face and then
this kid's face grows up and you watch
him become the boy at the funeral
so goes BAM he's the boy the funeral BAM
he's a boy in [ __ ] prep school
getting punched in the face BAM he's in
the Himalayas fighting [ __ ] ninjas
BAM you know and then finally BAM he's
Batman and he's got like the hardened
features and [ __ ] you and I'm sad and
he's punching somebody one of the
greatest [ __ ] pieces of Batman
anything ever produced this guy did it
man and out god I said ma'am I yeah cuz
he's like something emotional is my own
it's a [ __ ] good commercial mark
that's all I'm saying but it's he's also
the guy who's the creative director I
think a blur studios he says that right
here this is a [ __ ] single I'm a what
the [ __ ] [ __ ] speaks the truth the
guy said I'm the creative director and
owner at blur studios just gonna go to
[ __ ] just like he [ __ ] said man this
is like like Murder She Wrote
when Jessica figure [ __ ] out and the
[ __ ] last ten minutes mark is [ __ ]
a modern-day Angela Lansbury IV chip
you're mrs. Potts and I'm chef and I'm
like I'm your little buddy I'm see that
dance that was my [ __ ] Beauty and the
Beast dance nobody ever did that dance
at that movie we're much more elegant
okay go back to [ __ ] Tim Miller yeah
famous people right in essence [ __ ] I'm
the creative director at blur soot odor
or blur Studio number two many years ago
this is gonna sound self-serving but I
got to read this burglar many years ago
I contacted you through a bunch of
channels to go see a kid dying of cancer
who wanted to meet you you said no but
it was cool no Isaac and you were kind
and noble enough to go visit him in the
hospital I remember this now this is the
[ __ ] killing part of the email oh and
by the way I am NOT a kid I'm over 50
like I'm sitting to go this [ __ ] to
get Tim noise got the world bottom balls
I'm over 50 so this was kind of my Hail
Mary chance to direct a movie every day
I'd come to set and my first ad would
call me quote the hottest middle-aged
director working north of Seattle oh
thank you again for the kind words to
know how sweet is that dancing so
immediately I wrote back I was a [ __ ]
kid I watch your movie please every way
I've seen that trailer holy [ __ ] in one
trailer he managed to [ __ ] make a
better movie than I have in 22 years
so I said invite me to the movie please
I want to go see it so he's those two
screenings coming up so I'm gonna bring
we're gonna see some [ __ ] Deadpool is
everywhere in town right now you cannot
escape have you seen the amazing
billboards
that's the skull and then the poo this
movie's gonna make a [ __ ] so much
money he's not gonna make force awakens
money which cannot stop [ __ ] her and
apparently force awakens is a mint that
just prints their own [ __ ] gears and
it's the way Disney forgets the good
dinosaur they're like who the why we
done made another movie the mediocre
dinosaur [ __ ] you
we've got the new Star Wars
at kylo Ren yeah think about kylo Ren a
lot did you see that awesome [ __ ]
cartoons going around online of its it's
just called Ben and it's like a chewy
cartoon oh you busy no no [ __ ] is
amazing it's electric it is basically it
starts with Chewie holding a baby young
kylo Ren
then she we playing with young Kyla or
Ben sorry young Ben which we never found
out is it solo Organa it would probably
I mean if we're gonna stick to the you
know domestic patriarchy we've been so
though so there's a little been hanging
out with uncle chewy and then they show
him getting older and they show him like
teenage and emo out and he's just
sitting there and Chewie don't know what
to do for him Tony it's [ __ ] it's
like eight drawings and it's as powerful
as [ __ ] you know the movie itself
then the boy storms off with emo hair in
front of his face very well Jon I can't
remember who drew it look about gujja
real quick and then they showed Chewie
sitting there by himself you know just
like and the moon beyond and stuff so
it's just like this kid ain't coming
back then they cut to the shot of
spoilers kylo Ren doing with kylo Ren
did that piece of [ __ ] in force awakens
and Chewie going nuts and then the image
is the viewfinder and it's a head shot
so Chewie could have [ __ ] blown his
goddamn head off which we all would have
enjoyed but then they cut to Chewie like
going like this like he remembers the
little boy and so then he aims to the
section he shot like I love the age of
the internet because it allows like some
random who had nothing to do with the
force awakens as much to do with the
force awakens as me was mr. randoms
named Tyson Murphy's a [ __ ] genius
I Love You Tyson Murphy oh my god like
don't look it up right now I mean it's
all over if you pray if you watch the
show you probably unlike Marc I'm how
everybody's [ __ ] seeing it like it's
it's amazing where somebody's art could
inspire something so [ __ ] beautiful
could like stand shoulder to shoulder
with the art that it's adoring and
what's beautiful about that and force
awakens is it
- is a piece of fan art when you think
about it work we're living in meta times
kid this is the metrics not the matrix
they're all in the metrics and [ __ ]
we're all referencing each other at
every moment it's kind of it is kind of
neat anyway Deadpool's [ __ ] coming we
know the guy who did it one of us does
drop the mic I do too it was on our show
he heard you he said he was like I
watched the show so he's seen you too he
wrote PS marks black is gonna be our
first official shirt all right so we got
a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] to talk about
man take this away you have dive in I've
been talking too much you talk I'm gonna
drink some milk do you do that as though
heroes do it does somebody good
marketing works so [ __ ] good that
that's like any time some is like you
shouldn't be drinking that much milk
does a body good and beef is what's for
dinner why would I not do any she's
glorious cheese oh my god we were
brainwashed absolutely sugar
we got a casting it's like a casting
rondelay really I feel this is like a
plaster casting somebody put their dick
and some [ __ ] whose dick is a kylo
Ren's dick it's Conny Nielsen's dick
Connie Nielsen of gladiator face of
gladiator Fame I'll be honest were the
first time we talked about this I
thought I was like Connie Nielsen I mean
I guess you can grab the lady from the
football show in Nashville oh [ __ ] yeah
which seems to me is like obvious of
choice as Connie Nielsen and kind of
like I would have I would have gone with
Connie look these are both fine
actresses man I can't act my way out of
a [ __ ] paper bag both of these ladies
are incredible actions but I didn't we
hear whispers of like Nicole Kidman yeah
Robin right yeah like what you know
maybe other characters I think Robin
Wright is still in it as somebody else
but Connie Nielsen is hip Aleta she
could play Wonder Woman's mom kids there
she is there she is you know I remember
her from well of course everyone knows
gladiator should remember that movie The
Devil's a - come on dude she's like
[ __ ] Keanu Reeves spoiler she
Keanu Reeves sister and at the end Al
Pacino spoilers is their dad and he's
like you guys got a [ __ ] like the
bloodline must continue and I wasn't
even a STONER yet for the devil she's in
that's a good that's a good flick you
know what happened that big painting
though right yeah big trouble
it's amazing [ __ ] ba relief like
gigantic sculpture behind Al Pacino's
desk in the devil's I've get which is a
pretty metal movie watching them yeah um
the thing comes to life and starts
moving and shed and [ __ ] start like
[ __ ] but then all senate returns to
hell in there in torture and [ __ ]
apparently based on a real piece artwork
mm-hmm some production designer
production designer on this movie was
like I like that will incorporate him
people have been doing that for years
and [ __ ] movies dude this was not the
first time somebody saw something in
real life it said I'm gonna do something
very similar in a movie right most times
back in the day people the artists would
be like all that's flattering this
artist did not find it as flattering was
just like I didn't say you could [ __ ]
use my sculpture in your movie and to
Warner Brothers and got some of that
[ __ ] Batman Kwan suite litigious
money that artists the Superman's home
in that case was gorgeous of money to
Batman V Superman's parents that man got
some money and they changed the movie
later on like on DVD or something like
that they changed the sculpture so it
didn't look like and they also added I
mean when they put it on like regular
broadcast TV you got a blue that whole
[ __ ] picture out because it's all
it's all look at my dick - its yeah look
it up you can't do that on CBS
apparently I get to CBS that's all I'm
gonna do the good way there's your real
Big Bang
alright so Connie Nielsen we got
ourselves a Hippolyta man she's the bomb
yeah if I'm cardi Nielsen though I'm if
I'm kind of nice I'm going did he just
call me the bomb was also late it'll
take a shower this would be so much fun
if I was Connie Nielsen though I'd be
like do you really think I'm old
play this woman's mother yeah know what
I'm saying I'd be like I'm insulted by
this but Hippolyta doesn't she make
Wonder Woman from Kleist maybe she's
like yeah at least according to text I'm
sure she ain't thinking about me she's
just like [ __ ] you how much you gonna
pay me yeah and like I'm being cast in
Wonder Woman are you who you playing Fat
Boy I'm like nobody
I'll play the one please ticket bar good
for her man that's [ __ ] awesome
she's a Danish actress she says right
here mark I know on our cheat sheet
notes yeah mr. Matt keek thank you Matt
producer man the stars of course our gal
our cars gal gadot Chris Pine Rob and
rut Robin right isn't I know she's still
in there
who is she she's not Hippolyta them who
Shimano a memory Robin right Danny
Huston I loved in Houston he's a good
actor man he's oh he's consistently good
and [ __ ] everything and David do you
want to talk about consistently good
everything David [ __ ] foolish you
ever see naked no kids go pick up it
ain't comic books so [ __ ] calm down
but educational it's just good go pick
up a Mike Lee picture pick it up [ __ ]
Netflix whatever [ __ ] iTunes stream all
over your face neck and chest and I'm a
Mike Lee picture called naked David
Thewlis like does this brilliant
monologue on the mark of the beast 666
the UPC code he's great in the entire
movie though movies [ __ ] a head trip
but that monologue is fantastic all
right what else we talking I'm good now
I'm just talking about [ __ ] that I like
a shot Aquaman yeah has a queen it's all
about Queens this week right oh my god
it's DC Queens knows universes which
would be a totally different movie
imagine a DC Queen the the DC Queens
continues with the casting of mirror in
the Aquaman movie
yeah Amber Heard you heard you heard
Amber Heard man I know her she's very
nice she's a nice girl
super sweet man yeah poor girl struck by
the homely stick no a lovely tree and
hit every branch on the way down but was
good actress and so that'll save the day
for ya she's she's actually she's a good
action number whatever - yeah she's not
hard to look out at all minute that's
your if you that's your queen if that's
Aquaman's queen would you ever leave the
under seat no no except when what
happens in Aquaman's world you know if
you follow the DC mythology things don't
go well for Meera yeah almost never
no no because then it's just a sitcom if
nothing goes poorly it's just we're
hanging out with seeing mouths fishy to
me
this is why do not let me do it in
there's DC movies I get to talk about
them on TV this week in fact what is it
[ __ ] tomorrow as of today meaning
tomorrow on CW this is [ __ ] crazy
cool they're doing a full hour of like
[ __ ] superheroes are the world to you
[ __ ] with a half-hour special about
the legends of tomorrow
behind the scenes introduction to the
show which premieres two days later on
January 21st second half hour is I don't
even know what the official title is but
it's a DC Universe movie universe
special where they're you know Batman V
Superman it's called DC Universe dawn of
Justice League or dawn of the Justice
League I think that's what it's not like
Kevin Geoff talk about movies yeah me
and Geoff Johns are the hosts man and
it's a real like primer for your mom
like tell me about the Justice League
Geoff like I'm saying [ __ ] that I
wouldn't say in real life but I would I
would actually turn to Jeff in real life
and ask a lot of [ __ ] he's a [ __ ]
Wikipedia
he's an EC a dick a pedia but not a dick
he's a great dude big dick opinions yeah
that's why you haven't marked good saves
he he's him he's the host I'm the host
we sit there [ __ ] fingers in my ears
my nose and [ __ ] like this Santa podcast
cuz they show footage new footage from
Batman V Superman they show footage from
the Wonder Woman movie that they're
shooting right now what the [ __ ] up yeah
which include I came and tell you though
yell at me but there are shots of Wonder
Woman in action doing some [ __ ] you
ain't never seen before really good then
the whole [ __ ] thing wraps up with
the debut of the Suicide Squad trailer a
brand-new one which is amazing sorry I
got Flemmi well clammy look at that
there's a new picture of the Suicide
Squad that's pretty awesome I'm telling
you man this movie's gonna like this is
the one that everyone's like well Batman
V Superman we're gonna be giant I think
this is there this is their guardians
the galaxy it's gonna be a sneak [ __ ]
stealth hit yeah like very quietly - 550
million dollars I think so like people
are interested my kid watches this
trailer over and over again the first
one not even the new one like on [ __ ]
repeat crying and I'm like why she's
like he's a beautiful she didn't read
comics I mean granted her name Sega's
and the moving stuff but she just liked
it
you know that's she's not the only one
or friends I'll dig the trailer man like
it's it's gonna permeates going beyond
just like our world it's gonna hit
normies who are like oh my god this
sounds kind of cool and can't get a
better director in [ __ ] David Ironman
higher air higher higher higher ire is
there I'm going there higher air I'm
gonna go with ire because my rir is a
[ __ ] dick you can't come see my movie
I love I've never missed an opportunity
says I love them to watch such a [ __ ]
astounding movie like great performance
is great acting like [ __ ] gripping
but he used almost every form of media
you could like desk we've used the
[ __ ] tiny ass no [ __ ] camera
Oliver Stone even you know a little
little I would Oliver Stone's not the
first person I would think of really
yeah
I would say that's the dude who did and
to watch like it was such a to me who
this is new like every every camera he
could like when I think of somebody
[ __ ] around with a bunch of cameras
now he's my standard but he's can't
believe I spit that out well so baked
let's move on to the never heard as
mirror is a fantastic [ __ ] yeah bring it
yeah I can't believe they're actually
[ __ ] this is not nuts dude it's like
we just talked about the casting of a
Wonder Woman movie in an Aquaman movie
and it's not like you know wouldn't that
be great now back to our [ __ ] lives
like this is happening and it used to be
that if one of those things happened
that was the big nerd news for the year
or a decade yeah we're making what yeah
next year who's in it
now the likes by the way it's just
Tuesday what's happening on Wednesday
wait you with more news it's crazy crazy
good time to be alive you know what you
know how everyone was like I never want
to be alive in the 20s I'm with them you
know [ __ ] what a great time to be
alive is though right now it's not which
is almost the 20s when you think about
the Roaring Twenties and we're getting
back to him all right man next story is
also DC or into DC he's all up in this
[ __ ] show mark legends of tomorrow
uh-huh which we talk about in the next
episode yes which we've seen we've both
seen first two yes and we didn't that we
can't like there was an embargo so we
didn't talk about beforehand so we'll
talk about it on Wednesday which is the
night before premieres in the future
yeah you'll hear it soon regardless it
is it's I mean spoilers it's [ __ ]
yeah
dope but what's really cool about it is
they're digging deep man into the DC
bench like rip hunter it's [ __ ] crazy
I don't know the kid plays amusing
something everybody knows Darvill from
Doctor Who from Doctor Who
there it is Rory he's really [ __ ]
good in this shows well you know is
weird is the white canary is Don
Draper's like nice from madnes I didn't
know that Katy loss is that her name
that's for me Muse was always like dude
and never once was he like she's also
the chick from Ned but that would have
made me watch the [ __ ] show
so they dig deep into DC Universe and
lure the bench gets bigger in the first
two episodes they you know they had a
rate up they add an atom villain right
away do it it's it's [ __ ] dope I love
that every one of these shows they get
subsequently less afraid to go [ __ ]
deep [ __ ] fast we know is responsible
Antichrist bird [ __ ] Jeff job yeah
man they're pushing that [ __ ] line
used to be people were like you could do
a superhero thing but they better not
like [ __ ] out superheroes or you're
gonna get smacked now dude they're
pulling straight from [ __ ] it's like
you watch the progression from arrow to
flash to Supergirl to this it's just
well six episodes before we see a
Deathstroke mask then flash it's right
out of the [ __ ] gate hmm and then
Supergirl is like oh yeah you want a
Marvel Martian just do it Marshall
Marshall Oilers you know watch such
Marvin the Martian for the Martian would
be awesome you just spoiled Supergirl
now I'm watchin look yeah the Martian
Manor
tune in for that but this legends show
legends of tomorrow man is they're
getting real [ __ ] excited getting
people real excited they're adding
another character mm-hmm I mean look
they're gonna add a bunch once you add
the premise of time travel throughout
the DC Universe you can go anywhere
which means you could do characters that
you wouldn't expect to see in this
current timeline or you know would hope
not to see Jonah Hex [ __ ] Jonah Hex now
you know we've seen a Jonah Hex movie so
it's not like I can't believe we live in
this time when Jonah acts like I would
rather not live in the time within that
just in their hands though Jonah Hex
[ __ ] give it to me give it give give
it to me that's why I want it back there
so I could carry it home mm-hmm god
that's fantastic they're just gonna keep
adding character after character dude
until finally you know I'm like Blue
Devil yeah
you know I'm slack racer okay
death the black race you're one of
coolest [ __ ] characters in comics man
but it's always mad you like dude on
skis you're like you always wonder we
spent our whole lives like how will I
die
what if somebody told you a little black
man on skates you will see something
that doesn't exist in the real world
back dude on skis black dudes in fact is
because I don't [ __ ] scare you there
now the gravity is already not my friend
I think they can make people live a lot
longer because I'm like I can't get to
them it's all good someone give me a
push why isn't everyone dying downhill
where's my [ __ ] sleigh we're writing
jokes all right here we go God the DC
News will not stop no this one isn't
good news though take it then you
deliver it go to a single get me out of
this new shot I will be the harbinger of
bad news there it is get ready to hate
on them kids mark Bernardin's here with
the bad news I went to TNT and I'm like
you know what you guys should do a Teen
Titans TV show because apparently that's
what TNT is not doing now go to a
two-shot what why I mean look I'm not
gonna get angry because that just means
it'll wind up in Berlanti land soon
ready much and they're gonna [ __ ] do
it but why on earth wouldn't TNT want to
be in this business right now
I mean according to them it is TNT you
tell me Marc I will I will tell you
according to TNT president Kevin Reilly
we decided it wasn't where we wanted to
go hmm and apparently the part of the I
said yeah it's not good enough we don't
want to go where money is and he said
apparently the problems were with the
script though by Akiva Goldsman
who has done both good things and he's
won an Academy Award
indeed for Batman and Robin no but yeah
he's worked in this business so [ __ ]
long I can't it's a wait they didn't
shoot anything they haven't shot
anything it was literally like they
bought a script they had greenlit a
script and they got the script and he
did the script
I wonder if they will flip it back to
Berlin Ceylon I mean they could right I
mean at this point they're just
characters lining it in a box let's say
at this point did they've now got flash
arrow yep
at the they've renewed the Vixen cartoon
so they think they're gonna add vixen
soon right to one of the show's legends
of tomorrow mm-hmm [ __ ] three more
shows they're their own network and
they've already got like arsenal and
speedy on arrow yeah I already got some
teen sidekicks cuz your managers every
night was just like man I got bet you
could do it at this pace a good game
they could be again like Berlanti is the
Shonda Rhimes of nerd [ __ ] so you could
absolutely just give over like what do
you want
Thursday's okay Greg give him anything
you want
yeah please like I feel like I'm one of
those videos where I'm like I'm being
held hostage they're making me calm
please give Greg Berlanti
the Titans we're all good here fine how
are you it'll be much better [ __ ] the
Titans go to Berlin seal and well TNT's
loss could be CW's game whoo I like the
CW man so you double your Netflix I like
my [ __ ] Jam right I can do with that
everything else I heard a rumor online
that they might be taking the CW shows
off Netflix you do that I did you hear
something I don't know why everyone's
going OTT which is over the top OTT
channel is what we call apps kids like
the way you go on your phone and hit
your Netflix app or your Hulu app people
like what Hulu alright I have a little
HBO now or go or I [ __ ] need it in me
whatever HBO's name is just like that
every networks doing that now and I
guess the CW from what I've heard I
don't know if that's true or not but
they're like we don't have to [ __ ]
give it away on Netflix man we'll make
our own app because then people come and
buy that app that's the future as the
television is backing on is all you
millennial lists cut your cords and
whatnot business is worried about how
we're gonna give them how we're gonna
vendôme television they figured it they
think they figured it out they're gonna
give it to you on your own personalized
app man the world's gonna get smaller
and smaller kids until you can [ __ ]
watch anything you want at the exact
mom you want like let's say you go oh my
god I want to watch a show with Sigma
the sea monster [ __ ] fighting the
ever ready ever energizer bunny and [ __ ]
you will type that in and go out and
email and within five minutes that
program will be delivered to you into
your brain yeah no more looking at this
[ __ ]
I mean CBS is doing the same thing with
Star Trek like they they're starting
their CBS direct or CBS Live or CBS now
whatever the [ __ ] it is and their new
Star Trek show will be the flagship that
will be the reason why you pay $7 a
month for CBS whatever defy media the
folks that help us make this show
they're the folks that do the screen
junkies as well screen junkies have
their own OTT II app man the screen
junkies channel where me and J do what's
in the box like this is the future like
this is and and it's good this is good
for you guys at home people are like I
want to make [ __ ] how come everyone make
[ __ ] but me the chance is coming up
because think about it they just almost
like when cable started and said another
they're like there's another row of
channels with OTT like they need [ __ ]
content like more than they've ever had
it before back in the TV days TV only
and [ __ ] couple pilots get made couple
pilots get chosen turning shows they're
gonna feed the beast once you turn these
[ __ ] things on man there has to be
content there at all times so that's
good for for you guys it's good for us
it's good for us I mean getting Netflix
announced I think it at the TCA and
delimiting Critics Association la-dee-da
that they're now gonna program something
like 30 new hours of content a week
every year but that's like two new TV
shows a week will drop from Netflix
Netflix I'm convinced is they're gonna
win this war without firing a shot
they're just gonna be like just watch
this and we'll [ __ ] slowly turn our
lives over to the machines because I
watch it on the phone that's why I do
this I know some people I'm fine you
could [ __ ] send me to the to the net
tricks future where they [ __ ] control
everything I'm a big battery that just
watches [ __ ] meth I mean they saw
Wally you know like you know what I like
the sound of that future
what's all [ __ ] Wally and I like the
sound like we're all flying and charged
during chairs drinking [ __ ] cupcakes
straw take
this future now why is it one sad about
this oh my god straight I wanna be is
everything I want to be alright man
[ __ ] like you know I'm not good I
don't want to I never wash it on anybody
me auntie what the [ __ ]
way to miss an obvious layup dude there
was a one-timer I [ __ ] passed it to
you wasn't me yeah they passed it to you
so easily you could have [ __ ] all net
dude nothing but [ __ ] 5 hole you let
it ride
you know or like listen to be fair
though finally the scrip wasn't any good
so yeah but they didn't say it but in
that instance mark you can also go our
give us an address then we'll move
forward them but instead they're like no
[ __ ] killers yeah I mean here's the
rest of Reilly's quote ok Akiva Goldsman
is a talented guy but the script just
wasn't there there's an unbelievable
glut of superhero things in the market
right now and if you have a really good
one clearly people are up for it but I
just don't think there's a need for one
that for me at least on paper didn't
seem to be screaming to get made well
there's a lot of qualifiers for me at
least on paper on a Thursday while I was
taking this [ __ ]
my dog was barking and my wife was mad
she she's on a period I'm a kid [ __ ]
left home on that day it also happened
to be the birthday of Captain Kangaroo I
didn't like it that's that's how [ __ ]
tentative the movie business and the TV
business are comes down there's some
dude who's like I met Kevin Riley's a
really nice guy but it's like so
arbitrary Kevin Riley read the script
he's like not for me don't like it maybe
it was for us but you know what doesn't
matter
it'll get tossed over God willing to
Berlin seal and him yes and then we'll
see the [ __ ] Titans done right never
get never get unhappy kids somebody
else's lost as someone else's
opportunity nice hope fiction thank you
hard left was a was pulled from [ __ ]
a development of trash heap if you will
turn around taken from a studio that had
opted not to make a Columbia trust I was
like when I'm gonna make this and they
decided not to make the movie and
[ __ ] Harvey once it was like give me
her garbage and turned it into [ __ ]
Pulp Fiction so just because someone
passes on something don't mean won't pop
up someplace else at a better
and stuff like totally true nothing's
ever dead guys gotta [ __ ] give him
some whole bunch of kids out that's
funny man most people like who are the
Titans to you because dude watch people
out there Titans that cartoon and
they're all fun and ants I can show ya
go Teen Titans go that which is fun I
[ __ ] love that [ __ ] but that is my
Titans right there son
Judas contract and [ __ ] well maybe not
that one so much but [ __ ] I want more
Starfire yes when they were all kids and
they were happy and should look at that
before [ __ ] [ __ ] once a house and
they all start [ __ ] as the original
friends right all right man we're gonna
jump outta deep now one more piece of DC
news yes can you believe it it is all DC
it's mostly DC yeah it really is so
check this children preacher has a
premiere date finally mmm we're gonna be
able to finally watch preacher if you go
to the South by Southwest Film Festival
great South by Southwest Film Festival
programmed by a good friend of mine
Janet Pearson who's working very hard
feverishly right now to put together an
amazing fest
since she's taking it over and that
festival is always big grapes is she
taking over [ __ ] sublime and she's
got excellent taste I've never been get
off the [ __ ] show really you know
number one it's an Austin yeah the best
food on the planet is and the only you
know the liberal bastion of Texas great
city yes you don't feel like you're like
in the scary Texas you feel like you're
in the [ __ ] people come on how's the
barbecue y'all and you listen to music
and stuff it is it's fantastic that
whole festival man and it's not just
movies like it started it as music it
also incorporates online digital and
[ __ ] like that but the film part of it
which my friend programs is for just MO
juice so she had she brought like set
there many times I think like the
interview was maybe they did there or
something else but they're bringing
preacher to South by Southwest for the
premiere so it's gonna premiere at that
Film Festival and then I don't know does
it have a narrative yeah
uh not yet not yet it is still one of
those like AMC is thinking I think
summer and they're also premiering it
South by Southwest the pee-wee's big
holiday movie pee-wee Herman getting a
big house yeah good for you mr. Rubens
right froggen and boy like he hasn't
aged a day
no like those shots of him he we don't
crack it yes Jesus he's always like
skinny and pale well-preserved I didn't
see that live show I was going on to see
my friend Ralph Carmen he was a big fan
um so and then I think that's it no
that's it for DC that's it for DC I had
some friends at the aginity CA things
you've seen the preacher pilot yes who
[ __ ] loved it
really yeah I didn't even know they
showed it there yeah like they said that
they'd it took some liberties from the
comic as we know it but not in a bad way
at all
they say the direct set that have been
direct the pilot um I think I didn't get
producer Seth Seth Rogen the great Seth
Rogen and Evan Goldberg the greater I
got a [ __ ] funny bit one day I should
bring that on this [ __ ] show when
Zack and Miri came out and didn't do
that well and stuff like Seth did an
interview with with us where he [ __ ]
does his like here's why the movie
didn't do well and he does this [ __ ]
story of meeting Harvey one having a
good meeting having three conversations
with Harvey Weinstein and Seth playset
and off-camera Evan Goldberg plays
Harvey we've never put this would be the
place all right they're gonna have their
premiere man we're gonna finally see
that [ __ ] show South by Southwest
it's gonna premiere the preacher TV show
and then sooner or later we all get to
watch it on AMC and we all get to dream
the same dream oh all right okay now we
switch gears to a two-shot and give you
the only Marvel news that we have to
talk about ya know and it ain't good
kids not so much it's really not even
Marvel news it's not even really that
bad it's just like a cranky person yeah
it's like it's it's man yells at cloud
Connor
Frank Miller the great Frank Miller
[ __ ] let's just begin right
then there yes without this man we don't
have our Bible I live by Dark Knight
Returns when I was a boy they taught us
in Catholic school if you ever have a
problem tell Jesus what it is flip
through the Bible randomly point to a
quote and that's the Lord's answer and
you know I would do it and it's like a
[ __ ] fortune cookie so sometimes it's
on point and sometimes it's just like I
have to say that what God wants I guess
that was what I one day got rid of the
Bible did I do that with dark night
returns whoever have a hard problem I'm
[ __ ] flip through it randomly point
to a quote and then [ __ ] read it and
it always solves my problem usually that
quote is I'm gonna [ __ ] kill somebody
this would be a good there are 11
working defenses from this position
Frank Miller is a genius you can't
[ __ ] take that away from him man he
reinvented daredevil he reinvented
[ __ ] Batman Sin City we all love
those movies or at least the one like
come on Frank Miller's a goddamn giant
that being said Frank Miller is unhappy
yes again yeah this time it's about
Elektra in the and you would think it
was a lecture from the daredevil movie
years ago but instead it's he's mad
about a lecture gonna be in the
daredevil TV show I don't know if he's
mad you tell me if this quote reason
that it might just be him like funding
around who there's election yeah and the
DeYoung he said Frank Miller said and I
quote they'd call it whatever you want
but it will not be the real Elektra and
protectively the author also added yes
I'm her father
so you know he might just be [ __ ]
joking around he might not be like
[ __ ] ball bars you know he might have
just been like a minute go whatever they
want that'll never be electric Syme
Electra's dad yeah I say who i say when
i say who you know what is that right -
as far as i'm concerned until he sells
that [ __ ] for a billion dollars to
disney you could say whatever he wants
about a luxury created her totally it
hasn't worked for hire for
hey there it is we're now the future
kids look at that it happened we [ __ ]
warp time through a [ __ ] black hole
and I think you're a legend of tomorrow
sir I you [ __ ] love a mark barnard
minute he could bring [ __ ] full circle
yeah he sounds a little low yeah but I'm
surely fine I don't know if he watched
their dough but it was [ __ ]
astounding if I was them I'd be like
thank you yeah they honored the [ __ ]
tone of what he created and stuff so I
think they'll do the same as season two
come on these cats can do no wrong I'm
gonna tell you something the people from
daredevil came to me and they were like
we want to rewrite you're all [ __ ]
useless life clerks boy I'd be like
please doing this [ __ ] do it did I
get a hallway fight can I please have a
hallway [ __ ] ya can be I was like oh I
can't do that cuz I'm very heavy and
that'd be tiring okay what if it was
just like making a grilled cheese but in
one shot oh my god I can do that I'm
Jeff loads call me coming back call me
bro [ __ ] five minute tracking shot
making that goddamn coming back there it
is folks that's all the news we got for
this week yeah and as a bonus our
version of daredevil season cooking hey
man you like this show [ __ ] subscribe
to the channel stop watch your primary
Jesus Christ it's a button press a
button listen to the podcast let's say
you're like I can't [ __ ] watch this
[ __ ] put it in your ear listen to the
podcast you could download it at
SModcast calm we got some cool home
shows coming up and we do call them two
different things the home shows or audio
ones and then this of course ya with
cameras this cameras we call it this is
the camera show the other ones the home
show yeah we haven't figured out what's
called camera show so we're gonna have
some cool people coming up man but don't
forget there's always an audio version
of it if you can't stand the sight of us
man but who the [ __ ] couldn't stay on
the side it's got Q we are I mean come
on evany and ivory of geekdom Danny and
live together in perfect harmony side by
side I got way to enjoy a little bit
there it is folks leave us alone
I hope you liked it there's a bunch of
news man next episode we're gonna talk
about legends of tomorrow and we're
gonna talk about the fact that I am what
directing Shh spoilers [ __ ] episode
of the flash which is nuts we'll talk
about it next episode of fat man Batman
till then I'm Kevin Smith mark barnard
and we'll see you next time same bat
time same bat Channel youtube.com slash
Kevin
[Music]
hey Nance me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder